alright it is time for hey treat male if
you've never heard hatred mail before
here's a reminder of what it is it's
like taking an apple pie filling it with
pages from the Old Testament topping it
with hollow points and serving it with a
side of homophobia right Patriot Man
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America because freedom
the hate reott this week has I guess I
should it's mostly he I should really
just say he it's it's so rare that we
get hate mail from from women I don't
know what that tells us but in any case
this hatred mail has come up with a new
new concept that we've not seen before
on hatred mail take a listen to this you
blew any credibility you are gaining
with me when you call Infowars fake news
I've been listening to him from his
start and he is the most prolific
accurate political analyst on the planet
so anything you got to say is suspect by
me good luck finding suckers to believe
in you you just put yourself in the
basket of liars like CNN if you weren't
watching you wouldn't know that Liars
was spelt ly e RS so CNN is apparently a
basket of people who are lying down I
guess is what this person is suggesting
right or it's that musical instruments
from antiquity those small harp things
that's called a liar as well it is yes I
know what my sense is I know that once
we had Shakespeare quoted in hatred mail
of course the objective was completely
anti-semitic
my sense is hatred aren't aware of this
small harp like instrument from
antiquity called the lyre we used to
call Trump supporters trumpeters yeah so
it's another musical instrument right
yes that very good I like that
connection so clearly we now are getting
getting brigaded I guess by the Infowars
supporters never seen a more prolific
and accurate reporter than Alex Jones